[Music]
i don't think i wanted to be an
entrepreneur
i was inspired um on a trip to japan
i was fascinated by the kimono
and also you know just the general
japanese aesthetic so i started to
imagine this kind of
idea around simple clothing
i felt a little jealous of men who could
just easily you know get dressed and you
know if they wanted to look professional
they had a kind of a uniform
i wanted to do something that was simple
and that was timeless
i loved textiles i love fabric
and so i started seeing these pictures
and
i imagined these simple clothes and how
they worked and pictures just kept
coming to me
and you know i just started talking up
the idea to friends and
i found myself at the boutique show and
i was i remember floating through and
going like oh i could do this
when i decided to start the business i
remember thinking
you're crazy you don't have any money
you can't afford to do this and i
remember looking at my bank account
going like 350 that's it that's all you
have what are you doing you know
but that's what it cost me to
to sign up for the first boutique show i
just took one little uh wall in the back
of the boutique show and i shared a
booth with two other people and
that's sort of how i launched
i think that that being over 50
the way i find myself describing it is i
feel like i'm like on a spiral and i
keep kind of repeating the same mistakes
but i'm just coming a little higher i'm
like so i see them i have a little more
perspective i see them from a little
higher place so i can i can
fix them quicker or you know uh i can
be a little more aware of what's
happening or what might work or what
might not work i can catch certain
things because i have a little different
perspective i think that's personal too
in my own life i see myself oh
that's the same thing i did before okay
okay this time this time i caught it a
little quicker this time i spoke up
sooner this time you know i
i actually made a change
[Music]
i never thought about
giving up i thought it might give me up
you know it might it might fail there
were several times along the way
including during covid
that i thought we might not do this we
might not make it so
um that was
disturbing devastating and um
also
i'm a problem solver you know so like
when things go wrong i like dive in it's
kind of like with sustainability it's
like okay here's a problem let's try to
fix it you know even though you know
that's a kind of a strange attitude in
life try to fix problems but i kind of
see problems as opportunities or
possibilities or you know something's
wrong piles of clothes that are piling
up from our recycle program what are we
going to do
must be a creative solution somewhere
you know life is long and
and like i said you know it's just you
know kind of keep going you have so many
we have so many
opportunities when it comes to work
you know to invent and reinvent
ourselves and to do amazing things at
all ages
[Music]
you